[Musique]
vous appelez à vous les téléspectateurs
vous connaissent ils vous ont vu jouer
la sphère weidmann et c'est ainsi que
marcel carné vous a découvert je crois
en partie oui en partie
que font vos parents sculpteur et
peintre alors ils n'ont fait aucune
difficulté
soyez acteurs et vous n'aviez pas envie
d'être sculpteurs ou peintres si je vais
bien en guinée mais suis pas arrivé
pourquoi vous nous avez trouvez vous
n'aviez pas de talent et si vous n'étiez
pas comme un lien qu est ce que vous
auriez voulu être bien j'écrivais dans
le temps puis j'ai bien aimé composer de
la musique et vous avez trouvez que
votre musique tâter pas bonne non mais
j'ai essayé mais je n'ai jamais écrit
comme ça quand j'étais le seul à me
comprendre et évite même vos parents
vous comprendrez évidente les parents
accompagnent parts
oui oh non je suis mes parents ne
comprennent très bien et vous avez
trouvé dans la comédie un moyen de vous
exprimer oui oui oui
qu'est ce que vous voudriez jouer alors
enfin le rôle de vos rêves
ben dans l'immédiat l'étudiant la sonate
des spectres de strindberg
et puis dans l'impossible le relire plus
tard quand vous aurez une grande barbe
vous savez je crois que l'appareil
qu'est ce que vous trouvez de plus
important dans la vie c'est d'être
conscient de soi même alors son époque
c'est très difficile difficile oui c'est
moi ou intellectuel que ça n'allait pas
et vous pensez que vous y parvenez ça je
sais pas et que faites vous pour y
parvenir
et bien justement j'étudie mes rapports
entre moi même époque
[Musique]